welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and now that liie season 2 is done
it is time for me to gobble down a slice
of Humble keyme Pie and confess what I
got wrong since we've been charning out
so many theories this is something that
we start to do after seasons are done to
go Title by title and uh when it comes
to Loki season 2 my track record wasn't
completely off but a few theories were
very wrong but I do this for you guys
because I refuse to be a nerd
commentator who only takes Victory laps
when I'm right about something and never
ever bring up the other time when my
theories were wrong this is healthy and
to up the anti for this Loki season 2
Edition I actually did a version of this
in front of a live audience of over 100
people okay let's look at what I got
wrong from Loki season 2 at the top of
the list is the theory that Mobius was
the grown-up form of Jack Oklahoma
McDonald's employee I actually tweeted
this right after episode 2 and then I
had the nerve to make a video out of
this I accounted for Owen Wilson's Texas
Roots his blue eyes and being a teenager
in 1982 his broken nose Jack's odd
amount of screen time in the first two
episodes and Mobius is longtime love of
McDonald's the 1982 timeline matches up
the region of America lines up yeah I
think Jack could be a young Mobius now I
even said in that video that I did not
expect this to come true and long time
new Rockstar Watchers will notice that
when it comes to these Seasons our
Theory crafting tends to be a bit Wilder
in the early weeks when the
possibilities are endless and then as
the episodes go on and the doors of
narrative possibility close Episode by
episode we tend to get more focused in
our theories so yes Mobius was not Jack
Mobius his name is Don he is a Cleveland
area father of two boys and a personal
watercraft salesman and apparently Loki
executive producer Kevin Wright even
weighed in on this theory in particular
let's watch what he said I'm going to
admit I love reading all that and we
would read all of it in season 1 and
something that Kate and I talked a lot
about in season 1 that led everything we
did now in season 2 with Justin and
Aaron was like we know that every frame
is going to be Frozen and looked at so
that anything that you're putting there
needs to be highly intentional and be
able to withstand the scrutiny of people
looking at it it's a nice way to engage
with the audience and be like I know
you're looking and we know that you're
looking so we are going to put things
there to acknowledge I know you're
looking and maybe some of those things
are pointing in a right direction other
might be there to purposely throw people
or make them think one thing so that we
can hit them harder with something else
my one fun one that I saw this season
was two things actually one that Jack
the manager of McDonald's was young
Mobius and that Mobius is maybe a
variant of Odin Justin and Aaron would
frequently tell me to stop looking and
I'm like can't help it I love it and I
think the show is better because of we
are engaging with
it so yeah I did get that one wrong
perhaps sillier though was my theory
that the key line pie of the TVA was
soilent green it was made out of people
Black Friday is just around the corner
so we called the good Folks at nerd Riot
and asked them to toss a couple of logs
on the deal fire to send out a smoke
signal for savings nerd Riot has special
holiday gifts up on the site and if you
buy any item in the collection you'll
get 15% off your second item from now
until November 27th that includes
special holiday designs like
fragile and best bubs as well as pins
patches vests and more plus we've got
our brand new Loki god of stories shirt
Marvel's merch and everything else you
might need for your non-holiday wardrobe
grabbing some merch From Nerd Riot has
always been the best way to support new
rock stars and now it's the best way to
find gifts for the other nerds in your
life as well so click the link in the
description below or head to nerd ride.
shop to get 15% off select items now I
actually first pitched this all the way
back in August 15th in a video there
must be some other waste management
process and voila the pie fed to the TVA
Workforce like clockwork the pie could
contain Trace temporal fuel memories of
the screaming families and the timelines
that were burned out of existence and
this would leave TVA Employees doped up
with the right mix of euphoria and
anxiety to keep them on task and to keep
them from asking the real questions like
any pizza day at any job the true
purpose is to keep the employees from
rising up and eating their bosses and
then I double down on it in October in
my breakdown of episode 4 we edit
directly from the steamy heat lines over
b15s face to the bubbling hot cocoa as
it Globs into the cup that had to be
intentional like the remains are
draining directly into this cup before
the season back in August I theorized
that the green pie could be a not to
soilent green and that it is made of
people when they're killed when we do
see The Killing room in soent green we
should note the Comfort color the man
chooses is the color orange so maybe all
the sweets that Mobius has been
consuming in the TVA are the remains of
his co-workers my theory back in August
was that the soilent green pie is
designed to leave the TVA Employees
doped up to keep them on task to keep
them from asking the right questions
I'll admit when I POS this theory in
that August 15th video I didn't think
anything would come from it but sure
enough I am pretty surprised to see it
possible right now after sipping the hot
cocoa D90 constricts and he prunes and
we think for a second it's because of
the drink but but no it is X5 behind him
recuiting D90 in the back hiding himself
just like Loki will do to his time
slipping self later and when the hot
coco hits the floor notice where X5 is
looking when he says I'm sorry he is
looking down at the Coco as he says this
could he know that the sweets contain
his former comrades or at least reminded
of their juices slashing on the floor
actually can we get an next five does he
know thumbnail does he know later when
they see the spill on the ground it kind
of looks like a person with two arms
outstretched trying to crawl away I know
I'm totally reaching but I just want my
hot hot summer Theory to be true mhm
nope wrong so overall my theories for
lowkey season 2 were kind of a mixed bag
like I remember thinking that kitty
Dicky would be playing the Sylvie
variant no she played General docks I
had thought that OB was the original
architect of the TVA who built it to
serve a more peaceful purpose of
Bridging the Multiverse instead of
pruning the Multiverse and this would
have been before Kang took over and it
did seem like OB might have had some
role in the early inspiration the tva's
design and the season does end with the
TVA playing a more peaceful role but
it's still pretty clear how it all
started exactly I had thought that Miss
minutes was made out of temporal
radiation and was a past lover of heu
remains maybe Ren slayer's extracted
Soul or one half of her by Camal mind I
guess I was wrong about that part but
Victor timley did Pitch his loom in 1893
as an alternative energy resource and
Miss minutes did very much of a thing
for he remains I guess none of these
were as bad as misto oh wait match
Jackman did further humiliate me in the
past week by declaring for the 20th time
that misto was never part of the plan or
W Division I get it I'm Mr misto now and
anytime these interviews come out my
feed blows up I get it I I suppose
theyve earned it Sasha Baron Cohen has
been confirmed to play Mesto in the Iron
Heart series whenever that comes out but
by now I think we know Mesto was more of
a feeling than an actual planned cameo
in W division we've learned a lot of
lessons I like to think misto made us
better he definitely made a lot of
others worse so my plan last week was to
publicly apologize to attendees of our
live show in Los Angeles we ended up
having a really fun discussion about
Theory craft but what I did not realize
was that friend of the channel or Foe of
the channel CM G was already planning to
gotcha me and turn this event into kind
of like a Rowdy Town Hall did our people
take the bait you decide hey it's Cass
today we're outside the new rock stars
live event on Fairfax in Los Angeles
it's nice on the inside Eric Voss a name
that we've all come to trust rumors
Authority on Comics Star Wars Marvel has
he ever let us
down I say he has and today I expose him
for the fraudster that he is join me as
we go in there and hold his feet to the
fire I can tell by the shirt you're here
for this mhm why are you exactly here
what do you think is going to happen at
a new rock stars live event um I have no
idea new rockstars is like it's like my
news in the morning I think that there's
going to be a lot of theories that are
going to be discussed to be able to be
here in person yeah to see it live is
like a dream come true I think there's
going to be a lot of Tom Foolery on the
stage okay I usually spend my Thursdays
watching Eric Boss on YouTube uh now I
get to see him live at new rockstars
live and that's exciting that is
exciting for me yes and I think there's
going to be just a lot of fun 258 is
like they're part of my life at this
point you watch a lot so many that
you've added an hour to the day and a
day of the week Rabbi yeah look I'm here
for two reasons okay I'm here to find
out who the hell would come to a new
rock stars live show okay and I'm also
here to find out um what you guys think
of Eric Voss I love Eric Voss I think my
favorite thing is how he pinpoints all
the music cuz he listens to everything
and I'm like wow I didn't even catch
that how tall is he do you think how
tall you don't you have never seen his
legs right 5' seven about 5'6 probably
want to say
like 81 81 81 right that's a safe bet oh
look somebody behind you look who's
coming behind
you oh wow okay just play it cool play
it cool all right don't even give him
attention cuz he thrives on attention I
know I hear that I got like a whole
Shrine of bro at my house well what's in
the shrine I'm just kid okay all right
maybe he didn't even acknowledge you
that's who he is that's the guy don't
ever meet your Heroes exactly he can say
and do no wrong in your eyes hell no
what about this season of Loki did he
get anything wrong
[Music]
oh of course he did I mean how much time
do we have I mean is I mean I mean
they'll make excuses for him you know I
feel like some of his predictions in the
early episodes of when he was breaking
down the show you know they didn't pan
out exactly got it wrong is what I say
definitely the soilent green pie one of
his weird theories was that the uh key
lime pie was actually soilent green
which is people he thought thought it
was people soil he thought it was people
and it turned out that it wasn't a
little wacky would you feel better if he
apologized for that tonight that and for
the McDonald's Mobius thing what was
that what about the McDonald's Theory I
don't even remember the McDonald's guy's
name but he thought he was important and
he wasn't he was just McDonald he was
just a McDonald's guy he l two scenes he
is wrong maybe 1% of the time maybe that
1% is what I'm here for oh okay I'm
going to barge in there and derail the
show and I'm going to get him to
apologize for all the things that he got
wrong don't say anything don't you dare
okay do I have your silence pinky swear
give me the
pinky do the thing do
it I'm sorry we have you on camera
kissing your thumb he got the Mesto
stuff wrong we don't have to talk about
Mesto we do he still gets on his own
case about that to the fire for it let's
not let him rag on himself let us rag on
him we all want him a Fisto isn't the
obsession with a devil sort of like
concerning to you guys not if it's
coming from Eric Vos he's Heaven Sent
man misto
confirmed excuse me mistal confirmed W
division reports that quick silver from
the X-Men movies actor Evan Peters is
playing a roome they all point to
another possibility mefisto Mesto was
hidden as an Easter egg by Mesto
mephisto's line welcome back to hell I'm
myoo
wasooo
misto
Theo yeah was very reasonable and uh
middle of the
road stop the show stop the show give me
me a microphone please well we don't
normally hand microphones to people Eric
Boss frauder
liar we will hold his feet to the fire
here tonight at new rockstars live for
lying to these fine people who've spent
their harder money to come here and and
and have a cozy intimate if I may say so
even tired I can't watch all the videos
they're
tired you hear that look like a separate
issue
when I say these two words McDonald's
and at Key Lime three more key lime
pie soilent greed isn't that
interesting I'm here to make sure Eric
apologizes for these lies here tonight
for you
people Eric okay I was going to do that
anyway I in videos promoting this show I
told everyone that I was going to
apologize for my bad theories I was
already planning on you were already
going to do that I was already going to
do that I was just oh well no I'm glad
you're addressing it no I I was going to
do it anyway okay well that's fine as
long as you're as long as you're taking
responsibility okay I guess we'll just
sit down and watch the
show G
every sorry I thought I had a big moment
I thought I had a gotcha moment you guys
are fantastic you guys are amazing love
everything you do keep doing what you're
doing it's great F fills up my time you
enjoyed it I did you look tired I'm
tired it was a lot of fun I really
enjoyed it what happened in there what
did they do to you nothing I'm just
usually in bed at this time same they're
all taller than I thought was like holy
crap what about when I came in there and
really like laid into Eric and everyone
started you're my hero yeah yeah you're
my yeah yeah I had someone speaking for
me it was so much fun who do you do this
uh for your own YouTube channel does it
look natural no you look like you know
what you're doing oh my god really
Thanks new rock stars the best thanks
Eric Boss and everyone for all the
efforts that you put into all your
videos okay no that's it you um just
close the video and I'm I'm out of here
just tell them make sure to subscribe
and like oh my God subscribe like
comment do all of that support new rock
stars have a good night
[Music]
good